and we'll see representative shuitt for
motion by hatch second by Schmidt
you're gonna get additions deletions or
corrections to the minutes
seeing none all in favor
about emotion on the consent agenda
move to approve second
motion made and seconded on the consent
agenda any discussion
all those in favor
any
opposed
need a motion on a post move to postpone
um prescription drug affordability board
rules
second
we have a motion and a second
we have a motion in a second all those
in favor
stay off go ahead
um so 20 22 91 the only comment on this
proposal was that the rules expired on
November 23 2021 and
therefore the rules have been expired
for almost a year now there are some
fees within the rule however those fees
are statutory fees and set by Statute
which is how the department has
Justified collecting those fees while
the rules have been expired
the remaining part of the rules are for
the application for certain
certifications and licensures
um that also accompany some forms that
have all been submitted to staff and a
conditional approval was submitted that
addressed the remaining substantive
comments that staff had
foreign
I'd just like to say um that the rules
as presented for conditional approval
have been in place for for 10 years
there was one minor section that was
deleted based on a statutory change
um but the rules represent the process
for what is authorized in statute that
is the registration of aircraft
commercial operators and aircraft
dealers and all the fees are set in
statute
um the other changes are tweaks that
were recommended by the office of
legislative Services rules Division
and the incorporation of the forms by
reference at this point I would really
like to thank the folks at OLS rules
division their knowledge and assistance
rulemaking I'll admit is not my forte
and they are most helpful and I really
appreciate it thank you
motion
motion by Schmidt second by hatch any
discussion
all those in favor
aye any opposed
feeding garbage to swine for those of
um Mr chair this rule actually we got a
last minute request from the agency to
postpone this promotion to postpone
move to postpone
motion by lying second by Schmidt we'll
need a waiver for this one
that is correct we will need a waiver as
um and we include the waiver
agreed any discussion all those in favor
uh for this particular rule there was a
preliminary objection that was tabled at
the last meeting so that is still being
considered at this time however the
agency has submitted an amended
conditional approval request as was
discussed making changes to the
religious exemption form and the
religious exemption rules taking out the
acknowledgment pieces on the form and in
the rule and additionally on the form
making the
section where the
person applying for the waiver can
select the vaccine making that optional
and even putting a disclosure underneath
that that if it is not provided it will
not impact the request for the religious
exemption which based on the minutes and
the notes taken at the last meeting were
the two changes that were being
discussed
Mr chair
so all the committee requests
complied with
um as far as I'm aware and I was
informed by the agency that
representative Lang had been in contact
with the agency as well to discuss those
changes
um so I wasn't sure if there was going
to be additional testimony with regard
to that
Mr Cham I'm gonna withdraw my uh
objection at this point and leave it
open for another motion to give the
agency you have anything to say
good morning uh Allison radmay
administrator of the administrative
rules unit for the Department of Health
and Human Services I just want to say
thank you for your help with this and
your suggestions we have made the
changes
um as requested and we believe this form
in this rule language works for everyone
at this point I want to introduce your
rest of your gang hi good morning Abby
Rogers legislative liaison for the
division of Public Health Services I
also want to Echo Allison's appreciation
for representative Lang's feedback on
our forum and uh we think that um we
probably do have an agreement on this
and your other person
uh
good morning Anne-Marie McCurry I'm the
immunization section chief of the
department okay
Mr chair just have a question yes
so I want to make sure I notice we have
um an amended conditional approval
request that has the new form in it
which I'm completely okay with and and
we'll be voting in favor of but it's
also missing and I've got to make sure
we didn't lose it that the original form
for the second half of this rule which
was the withdrawal is still included in
the request
thank you
given that Mr chair I moved to approve
motion by laying a second by Schmidt
discussion
yes
good morning I hope just want to mention
the department needs to
better control who's allowed to put
forms up on the their website and that
yes
see no further discussion all those in
favor
Department of Business and economic
affairs
all right this is a Bea rule on the
Broadband managing matching Grant
initiative
um it's an interim role because the
statute just changed and I apologize
this was actually Kim's rule so I'm I'm
not quite up to speed
um there are several Clarity and
legislative intent questions
um and I I think many of them I actually
just saw one that we could remove
um and then there are some more that
that probably need to be clarified
um it's kind of
most of the comments deal with the
different forms and what information
needs to go on the forums some of them
deal with Federal guidance and federal
language that's not entirely clear
um and so your deadline is not until the
23rd you could postpone this or you
could do a preliminary objection
um well let's you all keep working on
thank you so
you want to postpone it yeah just keep
uh no no it does not need a waiver
nope
yes
move to adjourn any other business
no sir
[Music]